anh Alo ạ Các bạn nghe rõ mặt Alo ạ
à à
ừ ừ
Chúc các bạn nghe rõ không nhỉ
anh alo
ừ ừ
Ừ mẹ không ý định tâm sự ngày hôm nay
hôm nay sẽ là buổi bảo vệ à
U13 bị thu của
của các nhóm là đồ ăn hay vào web chuyên
sâu đây là bây giờ sẽ có tiền cấu tạo
phòng rồi các bạn tham gia nhé
[âm nhạc]
không nhập Thì chiều cốt để mô các thủ
thứ tính năng các bạn đã là đại khái thế
Ở nhà chả thêm cả em
chị à các bạn không cần phải sâu cả cốt
đâu mà chị Tuần sau giao diện để mua
tính Lan thôi không Không cần phải sâu
cốt để không quan tâm cốt mày nữa
ở bờ cốt các bạn thế nào cũng được miễn
là chạy được rồi về sau và các bạn nào
nhóm nào muốn mình kiểu view code để mà
tối ưu các thử cái thứ thì thì sẽ cậu
nói sau hôm nay thì
xem cơ bản về hôm nay nếu mà cơ bản
nhiều lắm mỗi nhóm thì chỉ cần nói giới
thiệu qua là nhóm làm đề tài gì ai để ý
cho tôi đi nốt lại nha
có ai
bây giờ mình sẽ thuyết trình không
chính là đề tài này
tiếp theo là tính năng chính
để mua tính năng chính thế thôi
Ừ hình như này thì rồi cũng không cũng
không có gì cả không Buổi bảo vệ khổ thì
sẽ không dụng do gì cả à đấy thì tranh
thủ là các bạn chưa on thì mình xin viết
tâm sự hôm qua mình là có buổi phỏng vấn
này bên FPT đấy thì mình à
anh như như mình đã nạ nó là mình dự
định là sẽ về bên FPT dạy vào buổi ảnh
lúc đầu thì vẫn ý định là sẽ dạy ở buổi
tối
và tầm tháng 10 Khi nào mình kết thúc
khóa này xong hết rồi thì mình sẽ về đấy
Dậy thì tất cả bên đấy thì ngấm mà các
bạn thì kỹ thì bên FPT chính xác ép Shop
FPT Software
Bọn ta lại em shop à
Ừ thì bên đấy nó có có một cái gọi là
FPT Academy
em không nói hay vợ Tao FA
chứ nó không phải là
FPT University
cậu Đại học FPT không phải không vậy
mà mà chỉ là cậu ạ
viện
FPT academy này tức là gì đây là cái học
viện để mà cậu lá đào tạo từ người chưa
biết về công nghệ thông tin cho đến khi
mà làm được việc nhưng mà sẽ gần như là
hỗ trợ hỗ trợ chủ yếu chủ yếu hỗ trợ đầu
ra vẫn sẽ là cho Fpt Shop quen này FPT
Software thì là công ty về mà chuyên
nhận à Làm áo thuộc các phần mềm hình
như cũng có blog riêng này phải nhưng
chủ yếu là mang xuống à Cậu áo chuộc ra
nhận dự án ở bên ngoài về để mà làm đấy
thì thì bên này thì nếu mà các bạn để ý
là bên đấy và tây không đào tạo TP
a
madea
các doanh nghiệp lớn mà FPT Software này
hợp tác thì
a bít doanh nghiệp nào cần p được tỉa
Lợi lắm cùng lắm là còn mang đến tô tại
sao lại như thế bởi vì
bởi vì đúng đúng là TPP
Hồi trước thì chưa chặt chẽ bây giờ chạy
hơn rồi hồi trước nó không mạnh với Ok
Bây giờ nó bắt đầu mạnh hơn ngày càng
nhất thứ hai
tốc độ của pp có gì Hồi trưa Nó chưa
chặt chẽ nên ở thành gia tốc độ của nó
xử lý nó sẽ bị chậm hơn so với ngôn ngữ
khác và ví dụ vẫn So sánh những kiểu giờ
ra xin shop hay gì đó nha Bây giờ thì nó
đỡ hơn rồi
ạ Và bây giờ Nói chung à cái page em bây
giờ nó phổ biến hơn nhưng mà các doanh
nghiệp tập đoàn cũ thì họ của thì họ đã
làm sẵn rồi họ đã xây sẵn rồi thì và và
họ thiên hướng vẫn là ra công nhận ra
vực Đông và vị thần là cái gì đó không
nhận được đông nhưng mà
Ừ nhưng mà hiện tại thì mình vẫn thấy có
tiềm năng ở tp đến ở nơi này Hôm qua
mình có trao đổi với biến họ mà lúc đầu
được bên họ sẽ kiểu muốn là mình học một
ngôn ngữ mới để mà kiểu dậy dậy theo của
người ta nhưng mình nói là các p rồi
chúng ra ở vẫn đang rất là tiềm năng vẫn
nhiều người ở học và cả và tính ra thì
pp nó học dễ hơn so với Java Nếu các bạn
từng học ra và được cậu sẽ biết cái nên
là mình mình thấy à Bây giờ Bây giờ TP
đang mạnh lên rồi là cầu là cái cái 8
đấy thì nó không bao giờ mạnh hơn rồi
tốc độ nó xử lý nhanh và chọn chặt chẽ
rồi nên là không sao cả
ạ Bây giờ các bạn thấy cũng sẽ rõ dùng
được cũng rất nhiều công ty tuyển p
Brazil này chứ không phải là TP là ngôn
ngữ lỗi thời hay gì cả Không nhá mẹ nên
là mình khá là kiểu an tâm rồi đấy
đấy cũng bảo là hai à Anh thử học
node.js xong rồi à Xong rồi khẩu về dạy
bên đấy vinod
gà ạ thì mình học p rồi thì không nên
học nút bị ngược Đấy thì học bác em hiểu
thế thôi mình như thể học sang ngôn ngữ
khác chứ không không không mặc p rồi
những sao nữ
thì các bạn là có nhóm mới có hai bạn
rồi
ừ ừ
Ừ ok em
anh em em à chia sẻ màn hình luôn đi
anh alo alo
Ok anh nghe thấy rồi ừ ừ
[âm nhạc]
cho
anh ngắm em rể ngắm 16 á
tiền mua luôn Bây giờ em sẽ để mua những
cái tính năng chính của từng đối tượng ở
trên trang web của em
Ừ thì khắc khách hàng thì được tiền vào
xong thì sẽ chọn
chọn lịch là gì đó ví dụ như chọn phải
chọn chồng đúng không Giờ ví dụ ví dụ
như tâm này
thì kiếm
thì đặt xong nếu mà đặt lịch ngay nhá
thì
thì có thể
kiểu trọng luôn Giờ về luôn ngày ngày
ngày gì
chi tiết
các em chỉ có đặt ạ
ừ ừ
bánh mì được cái này
anh bình tĩnh mình đánh cá bình tĩnh đã
quay qua lại quay lại bên Tân đi sao bạn
lại đúng cái bạn lại đúng cái sân vừa
đạt ý
rất là đông á
tra nó nó tại đây đoàn đã đặt rồi trên
coi cho nó dễ
karaoke Thế bây giờ có tình huống ở bên
admin em kiểm tra cảm biến amin nhỉ À
nếu mà giả sử hai admin cùng và cùng
diệt một gái thì
cùng duyệt 222 lịch đạt thì thì có nhận
được không em đã kiểm tra lại đấy chưa
đăng ký Kênh Đón lấy thì chưa nhưng mà
em tính tính chắc em hiểu à
chị sẽ lấy Đợi anh xử lý lại sau cánh
chưa nghĩ người đến trường hợp này Cùng
với mà cùng lúc thì chắc chắc chỉ là em
cho nó
cho nó kiểu Triều Tiên hàng là bấm trước
đúng không
như kiểm tra ngay bên người dùng ngay
thôi em kiểm tra rồi em ạ Nó tồn tại rồi
thôi Cái cái đoạn này thật ra thì
trải nghiệm người dùng sẽ hơi tệ một tí
điểm là bởi vì nó đã được đặt rồi ý thì
ra là kiểu khi em và cái trang này Đầu
tiên thì đã dán lẽ là phải ạ phải kiểu
không đi xây bồ cái phần kia đi ngày đái
cái này hết là em Lúc nãy giờ em đi bắt
lại cho nên nó vẫn còn sẽ lấy cái
này mà khi mà vào thì mày tổng tổng kia
ngày 16 vậy á thì bây giờ này nó không
được được được à
cái cái cái bài toán ở đây đó là em nên
chọn luôn cả ngày đá lúc đầu nữa đúng
không mặc định ngày hôm nay em có thể
chọn được ngày đá quá không
Cái này chắc chắn này lúc lúc đầu thì
không nhưng mà để em đi đầy bồ bên giao
diện thôi em đã bắt bác en xử lý virus
chưa ạ Hình
như là có rồi sao này đỡ kiểm tra lại
Ok Hà Nội dung nào về tính năng đặt lịch
thì có vẻ tương đối ổn rồi Thế bây giờ
còn tính năng gì nữa
sẽ như thế nào với kia cái đặt này kiếm
kiểu tóc nhất thời gian toán thời gian
kiểu kiểm tra cá mà song song nhỏ xanh
Sơn lớn căng to hơi bị tốn thời gian đó
để thực hành cái đấy nó khó ở bên cái
đặt lịch xinh xắn này em chọn mày Cái
tìm kiếm đi Em tìm kiếm cho em thế này
điền như thế đâu Cái cái thận chọn giờ
ấy nếu họ không họ không đúng như thế
thì nó sẽ học ra Nó kiểu nó chỉ sợ nó sĩ
Zen sẽ không có tính cái không Vậy à Đâu
em thử điện mỗi số 7 trong cái kia cơ mà
Vậy thì lo món làm như thế nhưng mà nó
không có con chọn này đúng cái khung giờ
mà mình
đó là chỉ riêng được hai cái hai thằng
đầu
Nếu thế thì em à Thế em có thể tra cái
để mà chọn rồi ấy nó là đế pic ơi mày
mình chọn có khả Chọn Lựa rồi
đấy đâu mà nhúng anh giống nó vào nó chị
nó không ăn được xe Z là sao nó cụ quá
giống nhúng vào nó bị lỗi người là rẻ
lắm lẽ nó chị nó bị lỗi giao diện
giao diện bảo quay Mình đang ở giao diện
này ạ
để con đặt
thì
có mấy cái này trên mấy cái này lên chị
ạ
cái này là cái gì đấy gì để xem đợi xong
làm gì Có xem xem cái xong của Google
ở
khu vực này này này Thực ra là cái này
và đừng có lạm dụng mà đừng có lạm dụng
Model quá nên hẳn Mở hàn trang mới để mà
kiểu hiển thị ra Cậu
chỉ biết đấy chứ không không nên lạm
dụng theo cầu mua đồ để quá Cái này thì
có thể dùng mua đồ được nhưng mà còn con
cái xem chi tiết này thêm sửa xóa cái
chi tiết đấy thì nên mở ra trang mới
sẽ thì anh biết tớ làm cứu khi mà bấm
bám vào nó cái mở ra cho nó được dù nó
vẫn còn kiếp này chắc được không thì
không em phải bỏ cả cái mua đồ ở đi này
xong bấm là mở ra xanh mới để xem chi
tiết thôi I Em nói cái này cũng tìm kiếm
tên em
xem xong thì em bây bây giờ bình minh
tĩnh bình tĩnh Vậy anh làm ra để biết
được là những sân đang được à
Ừ cái này thì cái này thì em xem chưa
nào nhưng mà kia xong đem được đã thì
phải có cái mình chắc mình phải chọn
theo bây giờ nữa à
Ừ ừ thì bây giờ anh muốn là cậu quản lý
bài toán ở đây bài toán ở đây thôi em
anh làm thì nó vẫn chỉ mang tính chất
tương đối thực tế là một người không
quản lý nhiều khu vực thật nhiều sân Thế
thực tế là là mình sẽ trang trung gian
để những cái chủ sân có thể lên là đập
thực có thể thêm sân của họ và người
khác mặt của họ thông qua trang của em
đúng không Thì cái chủ sân nó sẽ thể vào
xem được là sân nào nó đang được đặc và
sân nào chống vân vân Và thậm chí về sau
đấy Ở thỉnh thoảng của thống kê cái gì
đó là sân nào được đặt nhiều này sẵn nào
ít Đạt Hải Vân để họ có thể xem đúng
không
cái này
thì cái cái này thật ra thì ở Chắc là
bây giờ hiện tại thì em đang làm chỉ có
hai đối tượng là khách hàng với an ninh
thôi đúng không
tất cả số balea nữa đồng nào
thì thì cái á thì bây giờ cứ tạm phải
làm thì nhất à
nếu mà làm kịp thì sẽ phải hiển thị ra
được cái lịch mà kiểu xem chi tiết cả
bấm Bây giờ em
có bấm vào xem khu vực xem vừa rồi anh
bảo là bấm vào xem khu vực chi tiết đấy
ngoài biển đi tất cả sân ra ấy thì sẽ
hiển thị ra là kiểu cái quyền lực ở dưới
xong rồi sẽ hiểu sẽ sẽ cậu Đề xuất cho
tất cả các gọi Như ạ hiển thị ở tất cả
các à
à à đông theo từng sân mà
ở khu vực
Ừ Mệt vẫn Ý anh là vẫn hiển thị ra đây
này
ừ ừ
à à
thì thì ý anh ở bên dãy hiển thị lịch có
thể là hệ lịch theo tuần Đấy xong rồi
hiển thị trong tuần và chọn theo tuần
kẹo như thế này đó rồi thị ra hiển thị
ra hiệu Xuân Mai đang được đạt lúc mấy
giờ sân này đang gặp mấy giờ tao thử cái
này chắc phải lên từng song với tao
cái gì có cái này nhưng mà lập như thế
này thì phải vào từng son sim à hay là
là xem được cái khu vực luôn
Ờ
vào vào cái bên vào bên khu vực thì sẽ
hiển thị ra tất cả các sân của khu vực
đấy đang được đọc 0 giờ nào trong tuần
này và thể sang tuần sau là tôi sau nữa
là đại khái như thế
Hiểu không
ừ ừ
anh em hiểu hiểu trai không
anh em em hiểu hơn thế nào ký cái kia
thông cái Thấu cơ này là có vụ khi mà
vào khu vực khu vực của cái cái cái quản
lý khu vực đó thì là không Câu này không
phải lấy lịch Nghĩa là vào khu vực chi
tiết đấy và xem chi tiết của một khu vực
sẽ chỉ toàn bộ các lịch đặt của cái sân
của khu vực đấy thôi
lỡ
một cái lệnh này nhưng mà nó có nhiều
Xong rồi bây giờ thì sao thì nó chèn như
kiểu này đó em có xe lên kia này cùng
lắm là mình cùng lắm là mình sẽ hiểu đổi
màu cho mấy cái lịch đấy để làm mỗi một
khu vực của mình sẽ này như có rendu màu
thì em sẽ chỉ cần được ư cư kiểu ngẫu
nhiên màu cái thứ thôi
ở
đầu tiên ở cuối cùng một màu đã xảy có
gì về vụ ren màu đen hỗ trợ thằng này có
anh nhớ nó có dịch vụ được có thể trùng
lịch màu sẽ khác nhau
khi sex
à Em hiểu không Em chỉ là em em
tuần và trên trong ngày được như này tốt
này thì để mà cậu mình mình sẽ sẽ nằm
được là hình dung được nó ngon thật là
thường là xem theo tuần này người ta có
thể bị loạn nhưng nó sử học quá nhiều
sân mời quá nhiều việc chung Xem theo
ngày cứ tưởng hơn như bản chất là cái
chuyển như này thì nó cũng không không
ảnh hưởng gì cả đấy là mặt tao diện thôi
còn về bác em thì mình vẫn phải trả đủ
theo tuần nhỏ
này thì đúng cái này mình ông cao tay
cái này chưa biết sử dụng cái này
xe tải thì em đọc tài liệu nó thôi thì
em chuyển đã là
đấy cậu em
Em dùng thư viện như bình thường thôi sẽ
rồi nó nó cũng bảo là nó cũng có kiểu
xem theo ngày hay theo Xem danh sách tới
có nói chung là ở tra tuần sau anh sẽ để
mồi cho các bạn phải cái lịch này thì
anh nói vậy
Ừ nhưng mà em phải hãy dùng được ý tưởng
đã để em phải lấy ra được theo tuần này
tao hơn thứ đã
Ừ chắc chắc là được
Ừ
chắc là em làm được à
à à
cần có ý tưởng là mình sẽ kiểu
hình giống A được cần phải làm thì thôi
bây giờ đấy Bây giờ mình đang ở ngưỡng
mà là chú ngao không còn là Face nữa
nghĩa là mình cứ có lý tưởng cho mình sẽ
đặt tài liệu cho mình tra xem có tài
liệu cứ do mình sẽ thuộc nhóm
Em thử thì các bạn thực trả thù ở đây
các bạn sẽ có bị một tí gió là các bạn
hãy tự cân đối thời gian cho cái đấy ví
dụ Giả sử tính năng đấy nó thực sự quan
trọng hay không cần phải không Cũng có
quá nhiều thời gian nó nói không Vân thì
cân đối bởi Bây giờ Bây giờ giữa giữa
tháng rồi bây giờ anh vẫn đang tính mà
tầm mà lý tưởng nhất vẫn là tầm phải
phải bảo vệ và tầm à đúng một tháng nữa
sẽ bảo vệ được không Bởi vì một lần Bảo
vệ còn phải một nhóm thì bảo vệ sẽ mất
khá nhiều thời gian nữa nên là sẽ phải
34 bởi bảo vệ liền Ừ nhưng mà nói chung
là tầm dứt điểm là là tầm giữa tháng 9
bác đồ bảo vệ nhà số cứ bảo vệ tầm ba
bốn buổi gì đó là con người cần nhờ kết
thúc buổi đầu tiên thì sẽ là sẽ sẽ có
thể sẽ có
bên FPT
Anh đang bảo sẽ có người tham dự này rồi
cả bên A
Bên công ty anh thì ca Anh muốn cho sếp
anh tham dự này tất cả cả đồng nghiệp ở
của anh ở trường cũ nữa ở Trung Hòa sẽ
có vài thầy cô tham dự
đấy tham dự với tư cách của
của người ngồi phản biện anh còn anh sẽ
có thể đăng lên cả bên A đi cần để cho
các nhà Tuyển dụng có thể vào xem thì
thì thì Nhưng mà đấy Vào xem thôi chứ
không không ngồi với tư cách phản biện
này thì nói chung nhà hôm đấy thì sẽ
phải
phải lên Nói chung là chuyên nghiệp tí
xịn thì rất hờ hững
vụ áp lực cái gì bây giờ ông
ông cứ hình dung mà bây giờ ông
Ừ ông bảo vệ thành công là có nhờ ông
gần nhau qua luôn được cả vòng phỏng vấn
ông sẽ được tuyển thẳng về luôn không ạ
trả lời phỏng vấn gì nữa Cùng lắm người
ta gọi ông đi sẽ về đi lương thôi
mấy ông B còn đang sợ là phỏng vấn người
ta sẽ hỏi gì Vân vân hoặc đủ kiểu thay
vì như thế ông về ông bảo vệ đúng cái mà
ông Đăng Mạnh hoặc thế mạnh của ông
Ừ
Ok nghỉ nhóm em còn trình bày gì nữa còn
tính năng gì nữa không sẽ là đúng tạo
mình mới nghĩ khác toàn mấy cái cơ bản
hơn
về nhỏ me là một mình à Đúng rồi yêu em
trước hai người mẹ nhắn tin không trả
lời nữa còn có người
Ok Để xong rồi Sao anh sẽ xin lại danh
sách nhóm mới ở về nhóm có phải nó ứng
dụng rồi Ok cảm ơn em nhé
hai năm tiếp theo nhỉ
ừ ừ
[âm nhạc]
vệ thử này sẽ là đồ án web chuyên sâu
đấy Đoàn web chuyên sâu tất cả những cái
à
ở những cái đề tài webb kiểu mang tính
nghiệp vụ giống như là quản lý này Đặt
lịch xong rồi hoặc
hoặc tính tính toán thống kê gì đó
Ừ Ok nó 7 trình bày đi
ừ ừ
à à
hai lần
Anh Đức
cài đặt tên mà à
anh ngắm em à mà giới thiệu phần ép Minh
trước
chị sẽ có quản lý nhân viên quản lý
các cơ bản
thiếu vài cái con
ở bên này là sẽ của vần khách hàng
tôi Tôi nhìn thấy quả
139139 giờ hơi sợ hãi Âu nên đổi ra ngày
cả giờ cái vụ đấy làm được
nhà nhà đỡ sợ
ít người quá với 9 giờ cha thả không
thành là tao đi mất
vú to
khi đặt vé xe sẽ tròn
vì số lượng vé là địa điểm đón
để thôi à chứ không có gì hết ok
sau khi đặt vé xong mình sẽ sẽ có gửi
mail về nữa
bên admin duyệt đơn đúng không ạ
Tôi chưa làm giấy Ừ nhưng mà đơn này đã
được lưu chưa rồi ok
cô đơn đơn được ghi ở đây nhau mà không
không không hôm đấy để mua Cấm mở ra đây
nhá Không mở ra vay không thể tốt đấy gì
tra việc mặc trùng hay các thử à không
phải đặt chung nhưng mà đại khái là kiểu
xe hết bé có thử chưa
à Dạ
cho anh lên Chủ tịch tra tới em chưa
kiểm tra
nữa bây giờ sẽ còn thiếu vài cái đấy
đúng không Thứ gà ở bên bên admin thì sẽ
chỉ kiểm tra mũ mỗi vụ về việc đặt đơn
sẽ thứ họ bị trùng tương tự thấy với bên
khách hàng cũng thế
à à Bên khách hàng dễ kiểm tra việc có
xe tồn tại hay không cũng như vừa rồi
thông báo cũng được nhưng mà là bạn đấy
mà xử lý
Ừ Nói chung là đại khái cẩu thử cái là
mình kiểm tra thể tương đối ổn rồi nhưng
mà trải nghiệm người dùng hơi khó chịu
nhí ơi hưởng người dùng chọn thấy do
mình hơn mông lung đoạn đấy
Nghe ca nhạc
Ừ ok còn tính năng gì ông nhỉ Vừa rồi
sang sang sang bên admin rồi à
ở Việt Nam
khi mở ra máy tính năng này thôi
anh quản lí nhân viên sai tiền lương
bí ẩn danh sách mà ở danh sách bên cạnh
là gì
từ ngày thứ 3 hơi nhiều quá người dùng
có thể hơi bị loạn nhỉ Em thấy bị loạn
không nhỉ Cũng thấy thôi
anh ra gì à Sao là nó phải có suet ở bên
này ra khó
đấy Cái tôi luôn thì đi lên chứ ông ấy
đi làm đi
lên để anh chọn Bởi vì bởi vì không Dạo
này xong rồi à
ừ ừ
ờ ờ ờ
ở Quản lý tuyến đường mà nó còn đến tiễn
đưa
ừ ừ
em Em thử Peter một cái tơ được chưa nhỉ
mẹ rồi Khi tôi thử một cái mà à à
ừ ừ
chủ nhật đi Hồ Chí Minh rồi
thêm thêm được đi
à Dạ đang
ăn thêm
không em
ờ ờ
à Dạ Kinh Di chuyển như tuyến đường nó
còn cảm xe sẽ là vua Quân quản lý xe
Ừ anh lập Quảng Ninh chuyến xe để thêm
ý nghĩa là thêm thì cứ hai em thôi xong
rồi nó còn đi xe để mà chọn á Đâu đâu
thì bấm anh ngồi xem mà anh góp quản lý
xe để thêm xe để thân xe Vào tuyến đường
thôi
000 đ
em ăn chứ gì
em
bị lỗi rồi đợi anh đợi anh tí
đây
Ừ không thì nó cùng một cái gì em quê
ở Gành Nhìn giao diện này à
anh nói cũng gọi là rất là đầy đủ đấy
nhưng mà anh thấy vẫn hơi khó dùng em
thấy khó dùng không nhà cũng Hoa ơi
mọi người cố con khó dùng người dùng
thích dùng cái này được nhìn trong nó bị
lạ nhỉ
Nghe nhạc hai con nhiều xe rồi nhỉ
em không nhưng mà một xe với có bảo nó
sẽ có một cái tuyến đường nhiều sao mà
nhiều chuyện lắm cùng 10 giờ có nhiều
lắm Em bây giờ thêm gần chục cái sẽ nhìn
không còn hoa mắt nữa một ngày trong chú
cái cái này bốn cái
phim hoạt hình Tom
Ừ Ừ nhưng mà về cơ bản trông nó
anh đấy Đấy là của em có một ngày thôi
nhá Nếu mà giờ sự ngày nào cũng sẽ còn
45 cái đúng không em mình Dung mà dễ
hiểu
I see you
em khác màu nhìn nó vẫn mắt thôi Bởi vì
nó hiểu Bây giờ Bây giờ mà tầm 5 6 màu
gái bảo ông nhìn thấy trang này như bảy
sắc cầu vồng luôn người em còn loạn màu
hơn ờ
bài toán xử lý phải toán tốt rồi chẳng
có trải nghiệm người dùng thì chắc là
ở tạm chưa biết xử lý như thế nào Bây
giờ em quay Bây giờ em tiếp tục ngồi xử
lý bên phần đơn đâu đúng không ở Nga và
ấn còn đánh xe mà còn đến xe nó có cái
gì
Em làm xong xe nhạc
cho các loại xe chỉ thêm xe có thứ tự do
đúng không ạ
Khi Chọn tuyến đường
à mình đang cố định ở một xe chở đến một
tuyến không đúng Âm Nhạc
Ừ đúng rồi à
à à
của em rồi Con con gì muốn trình bày rõ
mềm Ừ
chắc còn mỗi này hết rồi
Zidane
Ok Cảm ơn nhỏ bạn mẹ nhận anh cảm ơn ở
giao diện tốt các bạn nhận xét là như
thế à
ờ ờ
thế là giao diện đấy Thì ra tôi hơi bị
khó chịu một điểm là cái thai menu bên
trái nó bị chiếm mất tận nhà
a
1/3 khung hình ở bên bên cạnh thì kiểu
bị nhiều thông tin quá nó bị xíu sửa lại
cả cái Menu nữa đấy menu được Ca là cái
ông chơi theo kiểu là
anh
em chơi với hiểu rút lắm nó đi cho nó
nhỏ lại thật gì à Nhiều Ừ đúng rồi có
thể ẩn được nhưng mà ý là có thể mặc
định lúc đầu ông Ẩn luôn đấy ông có kiểu
để devit cổng cơ khí hậu không muốn
thích bấm vào thì Ông mới bấm vào được
lót ra còn không mọi vị ẩn cạnh bạn cả
cho cái thang máy luôn nó bé lại một tí
đấy thậm chí là mấy ông thích thì không
phải là ẩn nhưng mà Mấy ông chỉ tiểu để
biểu tượng hơn được người dùng dùng một
tí mà giờ sẽ hình dung được biểu tượng
các thứ mà Thì làm sao cho để cái giao
diện cái giao diện để mà quản lý người
ta dễ nhìn nhất vì vừa rồi cái lịch nó
nhìn nó bị yếu quá rồi kết hợp việc là
danh sách ở bên cạnh đúng không ạ
ổn rồi Ok Nhắn tiếp theo
các cơ trên 7 trước hỏi à
em có cái gì để mua về đây em gửi chắc
gì cái em đã làm nữa đúng Anh em trước
thì còn sửa
I Pray
Anh đang
à à
anh alo alo anh thấy giờ Ok em anh thấy
ừ ừ
Ở nhóm em làm về quản lý lớp
xe tải
ừ ừ
trung tâm khu nhỏ
thì con giống mình mới làm về phần quản
lý chính thôi Đây là ngày dòng này chúng
ta sẽ có thể em sinh viên từ file
hoặc là thêm một người phục ông ạ
ở
xem thêm sự chó không
em
hết thì mình có thể
có có buổi họp
giáo viên thì
ở đất nước này có lịch đời này không thể
thay đổi được nữa là diễn viên hay ca
một lớp thể dẫn tới phải thêm sinh viên
phần lớn
tao lên thử chọn anh về rồi
đấy thì lần trước anh có hình như anh
từng góp ý rồi thì các bạn nên có phải
ấn nút tải về một cái file mẫu để người
dùng hiểu chứ không người dùng sẽ không
hiểu được là là cần phải tải lên file
như thế nào đúng không ạ Đúng là giờ ra
làm nó Bên Ấy Bên Này có rồi à
ở bên này có quên video OK
Ừ mình lúc này nó đời sinh viên à
sinh viên em dạy kênh 15 115 bọn
Ừ
mình quy ước Hải trong cốc à à
Nam Á
S II
anh Trách Em Vô Cùng
sẽ có thể xem thêm từ xóa thôi là
ngày bắt đầu
nhiêu buổi sẽ kết thúc không để chị ạ
em đã học được bao nhiêu buổi từ làm
được đấy
em đã học bao nhiêu Buổi tự động tính là
xong rồi lúc đấy sẽ có một cái ước lượng
mình sẽ ước lượng là đến ngày bao nhiêu
kết thúc nó sẽ thêm một cột không không
còn lưu BB đúng không Mà một cột cột
kiểu là kiểu expect and kiểu này ước
lượng ngày sẽ kết thúc đúng không Nếu mà
theo cài á nếu mà theo cái kiểu
ngày bắt đầu đấy thôi -
những buổi kia đúng không thử Cá thứ cái
đoạn đấy chắc là có gì Nếu mặt em Em cứ
thử mò đi xong rồi không được thì anh sẽ
chỉ thấy cô cho em hẹn em thì các bạn
cái này
rồi Ok
cái này nhé mà nó sẽ có thật thì mình sẽ
có các kiểu tạo dáng bên này
thì mình sẽ để xem kiểu này
anh em không thấy thằng bạn em không
biết thì cứ để xem xóa thế này đâu
Anh
xóa đi về Xóa lịch học
cái mà đã chạy thôi
chị sẽ có một cái lịch còn bên bên giật
bên diễn viên với học sinh thì sẽ không
có lịch khác nó sẽ để ý
ờ ờ ờ
anh k
đánh bạn ạ
anh em và làm phân quyền không coi
[âm nhạc]
Ok
tao về
anh
em đó nhớ được cơm
vì thế bất buộc phải nhớ hôm để mô mở đã
ra tay đi
sinh ý
à à
thôi
em học sinh thơ thống kê nhạc thông báo
từ Gmail
anh
lịch sử thì nó sẽ có các ngài những ngày
mà chơi điện cho anh thì nó sẽ hiện thêm
cái dấu này đây ta Trên Điểm danh những
ngày điểm danh rồi thì nó sẽ có rồi đấy
đang ấy phải chị có lịch sử điểm danh
cậu sau Tết này này ở bên bên bên sinh
viên
xe tải nhạc đúng không
Ê mày biết sinh viên đấy Hôm nay bỏ học
đấy Thì thực tế giống như hồi trước ở
trường ai á thì nó sẽ là còn quan điểm
là môn này có bao nhiêu buổi nó nheo mày
đã học môn này bao nhiêu tuổi đấy Mày đã
nghỉ cho anh buổi vẫn Vân khi màn hình
xem chi tiết một buổi học gì đó thì lo
cái gì đấy thì nó quan tâm giả sự đấy
giống như là sinh viên các bạn thôi các
bạn nghĩ các bạn sẽ còn được nghỉ bao
nhiêu buổi nữa Trước khi bị cấm đi đã
đúng không đấy thì bao nhiêu buổi nữa
phải thi Văn Văn cái ấn nó xem chi tiết
mà Tại Xem chi tiết hả Ừ
ở đây là một điểm danh rồi à
Chị
Thơ ca điểm nhanh rồi thì à Tùy Tùy còn
ơi Không cho con cho sửa điểm danh không
anh em em nghĩ là nên nên để cho nó qua
ngày thì sẽ không được điểm danh hoặc
chỉnh sửa trong ngày đó thôi Anh nghĩ
đây như vậy Xong tao không biết thằng
nào
được
là như thế nào nhỉ
không xài được đâu
Ừ tớ thế hệ thấy thì cái dạo này hơi sai
đúng không ạ
Ừ ừ ok quay quay lại bên bên vừa rồi gỡ
cái giao diện vừa rồi nó hơi bị
em bị khó nhìn
Ê này nhìn nó diện này nên hiển thị
trong quyển lịch chồng nhưng rồi tốt
họ cảm nhạc
đề
tài tử lịch thi 60 cầu
chú chó tháng đúng không
Ờ
sôi quyển lịch đấy Có thể bấm và nút thì
sẽ địa điểm danh
Wattpad thì không kiểu mở hạn tác mới để
điểm danh như bình thường gặp như vừa
rồi được à
khi con gì nào nhỉ à
3 cách làm đâu
Ừ ok nghĩa là Trang xanh của em thì bài
toán đó là tạo lớp bổ túc đúng không ạ
thì cái yếu tố khi mà tạo một lớp bổ túc
nó là như nào nó là là phải đủ lượng
sinh viên này mới mở lớp mà đúng không
Hay như nào Giờ chỉ cần
để ý
khi sex
lớp và sinh viên thôi Còn bây giờ thì em
chưa tính đến việc đấy
ừ đấy thế thì ra là em bị bị Hơi bị quên
mất cái đề mục tiêu ban đầu rồi đó làm
cái gì phải đủ nó tự nhiên và bà là 15
người đúng không Thì em sẽ chưa Còn nút
kích hoạt lớp đấy thì kích hoạt lớp thì
sẽ nghĩa là sao nghĩa là cái cái start
bit của nó đàn nun em dễ chỉ cần kiểm
tra ta bếp còn là luôn thì em hiển thị
nút kích hoạt lớp nó khi bấm nút cái
hoạt lớp thì sẽ cho chọn ngày để mà kế
hoạt có thể là ngày hôm nay học ạ ngày
nào đó tùy Đúng rồi cho người dùng chọn
dùng khi ở bấm kế hoạt lớp xong rồi chọn
ngày Sao không đi thì sẽ tự động tự động
đúng không tự động kiểu à
à à Nói chung là không còn nút kích hoạt
lớp có thử nữa nhưng mà mình mình sẽ
phải có cái Tí Nam đấy Cái đấy Cái đầu
tiên một cái tạo lớp bổ túc mà đúng
không nó không phải cả lớp cố định anh ạ
hỗ trợ lý ok con còn gì nhỉ
chưa
Ừ Ok Cảm ơn em
à còn giống tiếp theo nhỉ
ừ ừ
rõ là cái nhìn thấy có cái gì đó lách
một tí ý
điều hòa mát tủ lạnh cho biết à
Cái nhóm khác đâu hết rồi
Ê mày mất tích hết rồi
ở
gần đến hôm bảo vệ đi rằng mày không có
bức cũng cũng nào nhỉ
anh nói Trung Hà hôm nay duyệt này bảo
vệ thử này
ờ ờ thứ ba mình sẽ chữa 1 chữa một vài
tính năng gì đó mà các bạn yêu cầu nữa
này sau đó thì thứ năm từ năm thì sẽ lại
ngồi chấm qua vài nhóm này số ngồi thứ
bảy tuần sau lại bảo vệ thử tiếp Nói
chung là Thứ Bảy các tuần nữa tôi sẽ bảo
vệ thử liên tục cho những nhóm ảo còn
sót lại không thì sẽ là chữa cốt các thử
cho các nhóm để mà các nhóm kiểu nói
chung là ở luôn trong trạng thái là làm
quen được biết cả bảo vệ thực các thứ
sau đó thì đến tháng 9 thì mình chốt
nghỉ mùng 3 tháng 9 sẽ bắt đầu ngồi kiểm
tra tài liệu ở
em kiểm tra tài liệu các bạn các bạn bắt
đầu phải làm dân với cha liệu sang tháng
9 thì các bạn sẽ phải làm rõ được tài
liệu rồi đúng không để mà mình sẽ bảo vệ
thử bảo vệ thật vào homa giữa háng ấy à
à Tôi đang định là mùng 10 tháng 9 đi
mùng 10 tháng 9 năm 17 tháng 9 chỗ mà
thực ra à là
tôi sẽ xem tiến trình của các nhóm để
như thế nào đã xong rồi tôi sẽ xem
Ừ mai chị thôi
khi bạn nghỉ ngơi với thực tại phái thì
San hành chính là mấy ông xác định tư
duy là trong cái tháng này là gần như là
phải xong rồi tất cả các tính năng mà
mình không Cốt mấy nữa mà mình sang là
chín mình sẽ chỉ ngồi ta làm tài liệu
thôi và mình sẽ là ngồi sửa kiểu test
các tối thứ để mô xong rồi trình các thứ
thứ kiểm tra Cốt cảm hương thứ và tôi sẽ
ghi liên tục cả nhóm nào cá nhóm nữa Để
mà xem lại cốt các bạn à
ổn hay chưa và Vân Nói chung là sẽ chữa
cho tất cả mấy ông kèm cặp này ông có
thử thứ để giao tháng 9 ở gần trưa rất
sẵn sàng thì sẽ là nếu mày lý tưởng thì
sẽ là Ừ mùng 10 tháng 9 là sẽ bảo vệ
xong rồi từ mùng 10 tháng 9 thì sẽ bảo
vệ liên tục là kèo Mùng 10 này cho các
nhóm nào mà kiểu cảm thấy tự tin nhất
thì sẽ bảo vệ hôm đấy Vậy hôm đấy Cha
tôi sẽ mời à sẽ mời cát đấy các người
khách mời tham dự Còn nếu Mấy ông không
tự tin với ông không muốn hôm đấy vậy Gì
đó hoặc cả cha hôm đấy trở sẽ có thể ra
có một nhiều nhóm hơn không phải bảo kịp
ngày hôm đấy sẽ là những bảo vệ những
hôm tiếp theo Vân nói chung nhà mình
chốt là để cho
Ừ để cho là sắm xong tháng chị nữa Gần
như kết thúc Kết thúc được khóa này cái
thứ thôi à
Ừ ừ anh Nam định nó sẽ là 10 tháng 9 là
bởi vậy chứ định thế thôi để xem các
nhóm Á cuối tháng 9 này xem các nhóm đã
gọi là hoàn thiện được đồ án chưa thực
ra giống như vừa rồi mấy ông để mô thì
gà toàn bộ những tính năng mới Ông vừa
làm thì nó cũng tương đối gọi là hoàn
chỉnh được một cái đồ án rồi cũng giải
quyết được bài toán khó cũng kiểu dạng
các hữu đầu nhọn cũng tương đối rồi
e k nó cũng không cần phải quá khổ ghê
gớm gì cả Không ạ Mình chỉ lại cần là
mức tương đối thôi Bọn mình hiểu được là
mình cần làm gì quan trọng là mày hiểu
rồi mình làm gì qua mình chiếu này ra để
mà hoàn thiện nó để mà làm thêm tính
năng nâng cao Vân thì cả đấy Kể cả đấy
chuyện khác ví dụ Giả sử nhá giống như
vừa rồi Tôi thường ngày đưa mấy câu hỏi
chậm như rùa ăn một
Ê mấy ông nhớ hồi về đoán một bảo vệ tội
sẽ đưa ra mấy câu hỏi thì xem hướng giải
quyết của Ông thế nào hôm bảo vệ Đoán
gần như là người ta sẽ hỏi định cái mấy
ông có thể chưa làm nhưng mà hướng giải
quyết của Ông thế nào ông có rẻ ông có
hiểu được bài toán và trả lời được câu
họ để không thôi chứ không cần nhất
thiết là ông phải cốt một cái phần mềm
hoàn chỉnh rồi không có một cái lỗi gì
cả đầy đủ tất cả tính năng rồi Không
không có một cái phần mềm nào hoàn chỉnh
đúng không Không phần mềm nào là toàn
diện thì tính thế cả đối diện sẽ có rất
nhiều tí nha Em chưa làm khi mà người ta
hỏi ông trả lời được giải quyết được
hiểu được cái bài hiểu được câu hỏi đã
đúng không Rồi trả lời cái hướng giải
quyết
cho ví dụ đơn giản nha ví dụ đơn giản
giống như là vừa rồi tôi bảo là bơ anh
có làm cái thống kê ở nhạc thì theo em
thống kê bây giờ cái trang của em cần
những thống kê như thế nào
ở đấy có thể chắc chắn đấy sẽ là một câu
hỏi tôi sẽ hỏi trong hôm bảo vệ đấy thì
ông sẽ trả lời câu này như nào chẳng thế
hoặc là
chợ hoa cà vừa rồi giống như tôi bảo đấy
Cái đoạn này anh đang thấy đó hả Nó vẫn
có gì đó kiểu phức tạp thì theo em thì
nếu em có thể mở ra đấy em sẽ giải quyết
nó như nào thì cho tiện hơn cho người
dùng hạn thế thôi ấy sẽ xem hướng của
mấy ông xe mà Mấy ông thực sự hiểu được
người dùng hay không hiểu được bài toán
nghiệp vụ cần phải phải tối yêu hay phải
xử lý gì xem không không ạ sẽ sáng là
không có phần mềm nào của mấy ông ở hoàn
hảo ạ phần mềm của chả có phần mềm nào
là hoàn hảo luôn ạ Đấy đúng không ạ Thế
mày ông phải anh Hải Cẩu
Áp lực thì tôi nghĩa là không hấp được
lắm các kiểu là
khi mình xác định là kiểu gì mình có
thiếu sót gì đó đây là lúc mà mình cần
nói
chỉ cần chẩu vừa thấy giật được mình làm
được việc nhưng mà mình cũng phải thể
hiện mình người cầu tiến cơ à
Ừ hôm đấy mà có bị lé báo gì đó có mấy
bị sẽ bị nói gì đó nhiều cái thì mình
rút kinh nghiệm và mình
em học hỏi thôi ông ạ
Ừ Ok nghỉ còn nhóm nào muốn nữa bảo vệ
nữa nhỉ
em đúng có mà anh sai thì có nhá
bây giờ so với lúc mà bắt đầu làm thì
các bạn thấy là trình cốt các bạn lên
đúng không các bạn hiểu được các thứ thứ
hơn rồi mà không
ở nhà chung à Tôi nghĩa là các bạn đang
đang trưởng thành hơn rõ các bạn so việc
là là kiểu tự học xong rồi Mọi thứ trước
khi làm đồ án so bây giờ chứ mình nghĩa
các bạn tự các bạn cảm nhận được là mình
cuốn hơn hẳn có sĩ nhân hạt bây giờ rồi
bảo các bạn về làm trong các bán hàng
nữa quá dễ luôn thôi
số bài toán dịch vụ Các hiểu hết rồi
ạ bây giờ làm và bây giờ tôi yêu cầu mà
Ông làm cái gì khác thì mới ông cháu vẫn
làm được đấy thì thực a đấy là mục tiêu
của việc đấy Cái đồ ăn hay như thế nghĩa
là ông hiểu được cách giải quyết bài
toán nghĩa vụ rồi thì ông bây giờ ông
nhờ bất kỳ trường hợp nào ông vẫn giải
quyết được
10 nhóm nào lên nữa
kết thúc đây À hôm nay hôm nay vừa nãy
có tầm 4 nhóm bảo vệ nhà có bốn này
Ừ nhớ con số đông lắm rồi nhỉ xe lửa
U23 nhóm suy cần hết ạ kê
thứ hai mấy 4
ạ Bây giờ đang Cứ cho là
28 nhóm sẽ ra chỗ
vì
thế một nhóm đã ok
thì alo anh hùng à Ok em
đi đám chia sẻ màn hình ok ok
anh thấy chị ạ
Em đâu rồi em ok nhóm em làm về điểm
danh sinh viên em nhóm 26 ok
Ừ hihi Biết là sẽ có lấy bảng sắp xếp
trợ Xóa bình thường với bạn sinh viên
thì sẽ có import file sẽ đi đi
ừ ừ
chưa Làm hiển thị là cái thông báo gì
đấy ok ừ
Ừ thôi à
ờ ờ
ạ Bây giờ là có sinh viên rồi này à
Ừ có môn Plus ngày ờ
cô giáo viên của em có phân theo chuyên
ngành nào giáo viên nhân viên phân theo
chuyên ngành nào ạ
nghỉ thì ra có bao nhiêu giáo viên dạy
cái chân hàng nào
em
không anh ạ Để em chưa làm ạ trên lớp vì
của ấn vào lớp nào ạ
Ừ thì cũng tương tự như bên kia đấy ạ
Cũng - xem xem sửa xóa các thứ vẫn chưa
có tối ưu thêm ở thành thị số sinh viên
đã thử đúng không là sinh viên lớp 7
nhanh
đang thì chưa hoàn thiện thấy điểm danh
đi anh ạ
à à
có lúc này thì sẽ để mặc định là ngày
hôm nay yên tĩnh của anh bác bác bác lại
để trước đó đây Thế bây giờ
ờ ờ chọn khóa
để em chỉ là mũi cho bên em hiện tại các
nước chỉ làm xong cho bên các cụ nhưng
mà
bây giờ khóa nào cũng có người lấy chỗ
này Không anh ạ Ở thế em thử chọn và
khóa xong rồi Chuyên ngành nào có thay
đổi cho cái khóa mình đã chọn không có
anh ạ Ví dụ như thế này chọn đây nhắn Ok
Ok lên lốc nó cả môn học cũng tương tự
đúng không Vâng ok ok ok
phải nói ra những lời đấy nhé Không phải
đợi lúc anh hỏi với nói nhé Cảm ơn đã
vựng cái các bạn có tính năng gì
arycadụng thứ vẫn thấy khoe từng có
khoai Xuân thông báo hay khoe với gái
chứ giao diện làm gì ạ nhưng những cái
câu đấy là cái bài toán xử lý đấy ok
hihi
ông thầy chi bấm điểm danh thì hiển thị
ra thông báo viết này
ô kê tiếng ngày có thể cho chọn ở đây
cũng đường hè mặc định ngày hôm nay ngày
em để mặc định ngày giờ sửa nào đây nó
sẽ có trường hợp đương nhiên giáo viên
thì khi điểm danh nhà bắt buộc trong
khung giờ lấy luôn đấy chứ ở trong mỗi
ngày nhưng mà giáo em không Hiện tại thì
em không làm cùng giờ em chỉ làm theo
chia cả chỉ có ca sở thì anh là ca đấy
thì em chỉ là là giáo viên thì sẽ còn
virus kiểm tra chặt chẽ các thứ thứ còn
bên A
Chứ còn bên giáo vụ thì nó sẽ điểm danh
Khi nào khi mà giáo viên quên điểm danh
thì dáng sẽ gọi điện để nhờ gió vụ điểm
danh hậu thì lúc đấy nên cho giáo vụ
thoải mái có thể chọn được ngày nó cứ
chọn cho quá khứ được hiểu đã đấy bên
giờ vụ thì không cần phải và đến kiểm
tra gì nó gắt lắm theo anh như thế
ca nhạc Vâng ạ
Ừ ok à
khi bị bây giờ xanh lịch sử điểm nhanh
có chưa có rồi
em cứ ngỡ của em chọn cho đúng
thế này trai em làm chưa hoàn thiện lắm
tả vợ
Ừ cái này thì càng Hồi trước anh từng
làm cái để chị cái này thì nó cân à Nó
làm mảnh nhiều bảng 3 chiều cái này sẽ
em em sẽ cần là ai phải đến cái số buổi
ở trên này
anh ơi Anh thử mở
ăn cơm ở em xem màn hình gọi đi vợ anh
sẽ có sinh viên đây đúng không có buổi
Đây đúng không Thế này và anh sẽ đến số
buổi giống như em vừa làm sẽ đến số buổi
thì có một buổi ở đây nó sẽ ra chỗ ghét
kiểu nhảy cơ
ở cái tuổi một này sinh viên a sinh viên
bê này sinh viên này sau đó anh sẽ có
một bản chất thì hồi trước anh có nói vụ
là là thời ca cái và hiển thị ra rất
nhiều người dùng sẽ rất là bị đau mắt
Nếu mà thật sự em cứ liên tục hiển thị ở
đi học
em đi học
Ừ rồi nghỉ này để ra người dùng sự rơi
bị đau mắt nên là ngồi đấy trường ai làm
thì nó sẽ theo kiểu chấm đây anh chắc là
anh sẽ để mua cho em xem lại luôn về bên
trang của anh
ờ ờ
Xin chào đi mua là mấy ông sẽ dùng trọng
à à
anh anh không nói được à cốt của anh chị
nhưng mà anh nghĩa là về cơ bản thì à
Hà Tiện phần nào đấy Ở nhà hãy sẽ hiển
thị cái mục lục ở đây ngồi đấy thấy anh
bảo là dấu chấm là đi học cho dễ nhìn
cho những cái khác và theo màu nữa như
thế này sẽ dễ nhìn hơn đây lúc đấy anh
sẽ đến rồi số buổi đây này Anh đếm số
buổi ngay trên cùng này kèm sẽ là ngày ở
chỗ này như thế này mãi đấy thì cái phần
của sinh viên ở đây sẽ chỉ có Hiển thị
danh hiệu như này thôi em nhìn em sẽ
biết ngay được là sinh viên nào đi học
đủ đúng không làm phiền nào nghỉ buổi
nào hay muộn bởi nào đấy chẳng hạn thế
và hồi nãy anh làm được Anh dùng really
nữa rồi anh bắt kiểu khi bấm ở đây thì
nó sẽ là nhiều chỉ ra cái trọng như ngay
khi chọn ngay xong nick ra ngoài thì nó
sẽ cập nhập ấy cả thế Ừ thì ở đây là một
cái để cập nhật nhanh thôi em có thể
nhưng mà kiểu này thì cũng tiện để em đỡ
phải có cái form Ở dưới em ấn để nó cập
nhật tất cả Đồng Nai đúng không Chỉ cần
nhật một sinh viên bạn mua thời điểm
thôi đúng không cái
anh như Đại Thái thì hồi nãy anh làm đây
cậu giao diện nó như thế này em có về
tham khảo được Không được Được anh cái
đoạn này thì em sẽ là đếm số buổi trước
cơ em phải đến số bữa trước em hiển thị
ra toàn bộ trước ở trên này thì không
anh em Em hiểu gì sau đó thì ở đây sẽ là
mạng mạng nó là mã hay chiều cũng được
Kiểu xem ngày em em sẽ kiểm tra xem
trong ngày hôm đấy thì có 20 đấy các sự
thứ ở chỗ nào để xử lý đoạn này cái màng
này thì anh nhớ là hồi nãy anh cũng một
công phết Đấy bây giờ nó sẽ nha ở đâu
còn bây giờ dùng bia ship mà kiểm tra
đơn giản thôi kiểm tra là do đấy Tải cái
đấy có không thôi cho nó dễ hơn tí
cho tất cả bọn này cũng được điểm danh
cùng một lúc mà này là chắc không sao
hồi đấy anh còn có cái vụ là kiểu Anh
Giả sử anh thêm sinh viên mới rồi đấy
rồi Không biết các bạn bờ bị dính cái vụ
lấy không nhưng mà giả sử Nếu và sự thêm
sinh viên mới vào trong cái lớp này thì
rõ ràng là toàn bộ những cái cũ của bạn
đấy sẽ được tính ở chưa điểm danh đúng
chứ
để Nếu thế thì nó sẽ có thể hiện chị lỗi
các bạn phải bắt thêm vài trường hợp với
nữa này Còn không thì cứ để mặc định ở
bạn đấy vẫn phải tính là đi học hết hạn
thế
Bởi vì là nếu các bạn để mới vào học
Thanh nửa chừng thế thường lớp đấy vẫn
sẽ cho bạn ấy Chi chứ không phải là là
kiểu cho bạn ơi Tí nhà nghỉ hết thì sẽ
bị cấm thi không
anh gửi cho bạn đấy vào lớp mới nhờ vẫn
cho 7 cấm thì đã bị buồn cười không
hiểu
ok đấy thì anh à Cái điểm danh em có thể
làm cái tổ kiểu như thế nào ạ
Ừ ok Còn gì nữa không nhỉ
Em nghĩ là hết rồi Ok thì bây giờ em cầm
hoàn thiện bên này lịch sử điểm danh thì
cái này vẫn có thể tạm ra lại đã em phải
được làm mới niệm danh bên giáo viên đã
rằng em không có phân công nhỉ là em
chưa Tại đang mới làm xong giáo Vũ nên
em chưa làm phân công để làm kiểm tra
cho giáo viên à đấy phải làm sân công
nữa bài toán phân công thì nó sẽ
Ừ tao nó không ăn khó lắm cũng chỉ đơn
giản là kiểu hiển thị ra
nhưng mà đây thì ngồi đợi anh ra cho
nhanh Để môi luôn cả tính năng phân công
của anh rồi đấy
tấn công của anh rồi đấy à anh cũng làm
tương đối
Xem trọn bộ khóa này chọn ngành này chọn
giáo viên này chọn môn này là sửa đó thể
chọn
hồi nãy anh có làm cậu vụ chọn nhiều ngô
nữa cơ rồi chọn lớp này một là chọn cơ
thủ công từng lớp hay là có thể chọn tất
cả các lớp học môn này
Ừ kiểu như này Đây là làm cho cậu đấy
Làm việc thôi chuyên nghiệp có tí em có
thể làm được đơn giản chọn một lớp phải
chọn một môn thôi tao Ánh sau khiến cập
nhật thì sẽ cập nhật thôi
Có ai đâu mà chọn đớn tưởng như thế
à
Xong rồi Khi mà cặp chéo sao bây giờ sẽ
có thể làm cách nào đó giống như anh hồi
nãy anh lát lại để anh chọn giáo viên
khác ẩn mình cái kia đi không nên chọn
lại nữa đấy nhưng mà
Ừ cái này anh làm chuyên nghiệp rồi bạn
chỉ cần làm mức tương đối thôi các bạn
chỉ cần chọn các thứ thứ như này chọn và
viên được chọn lớp Thế là xong đúng
không chọn là giáo viên chọn môn nhưng
mà ý anh à
nhiều bạn khi mà chọn các bạn đã chọn
giáo viên chọn lớp chọn môn nó sẽ rất là
dễ bị loạn mà nên phải chọn khóa xong
rồi chọn ngành xong rồi mình thì là giáo
viên như thế này thì nó mới chuẩn hơn
nhiều không thấy là tâm bước từng bước
như thế nó sẽ chọn hơn nhiều ai phải
chọn môn này sao chọn lớp các thử thứ
nghĩa hãy ít nhất phải có những cái này
đấy có những cái tính năng nâng cao hơn
là chọn nhiều môn nên chọn nhiều lớp thì
tính sau chứ nó lại và và khi chọn xong
khi mà ấn cập nhật đấy thì bạn chắc là
mình phải xóa hết
em xóa hết cả à dữ liệu cũ à lớp đấy
được học Hà lớp 7 môn lấy được học với
giáo viên khác phải bị ghi đè lên đúng
không sẽ dùng cái Hà mất date August đấy
nó sẽ ghi đè lên cái cũ hoặc em chuyển
cho anh xóa rồi anh đi suốt mà vẫn được
lại Ok nghỉ Hoàng Ok anh
đấy Xong rồi thì bên bên giáo viên khi
mở giáo viên đăng nhập vào thì giáo viên
sẽ chỉ khi chọn à giáo viên này
cho học viên khi đăng nhập vào ứng
Có ai còn sợ nhỡ tài khoản giáo viên của
anh bởi
à à
nhập vào thì k là
Để anh xem đã nhắc nhở anh chứ
à à
ừ ừ
đã mở
du
lịch biển đây
Em
chọn lớp đáy soi sẽ hiển thị ra như này
nghĩa là giáo viên không cần phải chọn
khóa không cần lựa chọn này nữa vì về cơ
bản thì một giáo viên sẽ được phân công
ít lớp ấy môn thôi sẽ chỉ hiển thị ra ở
đây những cái môn mà những cái lớp mà
giáo viên được phân công thôi em hiểu
vào trong hội thế thôi bây giờ viên thì
nó sẽ thì đơn giản mà Thì chị điểm danh
này sau khi hiển thị lịch sử điểm danh
Nếu mà có cái thì đây anh có cái vụ
chị đã xem lịch sử điểm danh đây thì
lịch sử thì nó giống hệt bên giáo vụ nó
không khác gì cả này OK OK anh ạ
khách sạn thế thôi
xong rồi ạ ok
a a đấy hồi đấy bọn hồi nãy có thai Đề
xuất cho tôi làm cái vụ này hay có thể
mới ông gửi giám khảo về tôi làm cái ghi
chú đều cứ gõ đây Cái gì đó ngay thường
giáo viên đôi khi muốn ghi chú một cái
gì đó ví dụ là ông này Hôm nay xin nghỉ
nhưng mà tạm cho tạm kiểu tạm chấp nhận
cho qua ấy Nhưng mà khi nốt lại nếu mà
hôm sau vẫn nghỉ phát nữa thì cho thành
hay buồn nhỉ ạ Ấy vào đây tôi làm đi
xuống rồi ai ấn ra tự động cập nhật thì
chú iPad có ai không phải mỗi bên bên A
không ở bên giáo viên không ở bên học
viện cách làm tình thế này nhá Anh tới
nghĩa cái này hay
Ừ để cho mọi cho anh cũng làm được mà
chỉ đơn giản thôi Thế rồi lưu lại một
cột ghi chú ở treo từng người dùng
dễ mà
Ừ thế thì đấy thỉnh thoảng sẽ có thêm
những cái gọi là Nông trải nghiệm người
dùng lên một tí người dùng thích dùng
phần mềm ông hơn ngon
em hãy tự nhiên có mấy ông xin tham gia
nghĩa
ở nhóm này không nhỉ
thì cứ như lệch giống như tôi và lại báo
nha Có gì mày ông xem lại xem thuê nó
lịch Nha và tôi anh sẽ đang thông báo
nữa
Đang thông báo mẫu tương đối thôi Ở trên
Tik Tok
Ừ có gì mày ông để thông báo chị đi con
nha có thể mày không tắt cái thông báo -
code cũng được nghĩ ra là mấy ông thỉnh
thoảng vào xem xe mà có thì không nó
không
Ai có Source code để học không ạ Có bạn
Bạn lên đi khắp của mình mình thường ai
đang đẩy trên đấy nhưng mà ra bạn nên
xem video để hiểu được cũng mình cốc cái
gì đã nếu mà bạn nên xem suốt để bạn
hiểu thì
nó vừa khó hiểu Nó vừa thường xuyên được
cập nhật nữa bạn sẽ không hiểu được à
Tại sao hôm nay bụng kiểu hôm sau một
kiểu đúng không Bạn nên xem từ đầu nó
nói trong mà mình có chia sẻ code cho
thứ thứ khi con cốt của đồ ăn hay các
bạn à tiện thể nó lại một lần nữa côn đồ
hay các bạn hãy đây nhờ đây mọi mọi cốt
các bạn vẫn là tài sản trí tuệ của các
bạn nên là ờ
anh không nên không nên cậu cho ai đó
một cái miễn phí hay gì đó chả đồ ăn hay
này để tôi sẽ
đưa nhà tôi vẫn sẽ xem xem qua cốt của
các bạn để mà cửa Đánh giá những cái sau
bé uống có thể khóa lại hay nói chung
gần như kiểu gì đó trừ khi ở có bên nào
đó được nguồn á
chị Xuka đi người ta tuyển dụng ông cứ
cân nhắc công việc có cho mày ra Xem cốt
20 Vân đại khái thì nó vỡ tài sản mình
bởi vì rất nhiều rất nhiều bên tường
kiểu dụ dỗ sinh viên kẹo
chia sẻ cốt cho các hư thứ xong rồi
người ta lấy cốt của mấy ông đem bán gà
Tôi không thích mấy kiểu như thế nào
cũng hiểu rồi không nên là mấy ông vẫn
sẽ nên hạn chế việc cả passcode hai vật
này
ở nhà ông nói chung à Là mấy ông có thể
nghĩ là cốt của em mới chỉ ở mức tương
đối thôi hoặc là yếu gì chị đó chắc
không ai dùng đâu không không nghĩ hệ vì
các bạn mình đang cút khuẩn với các bạn
Mình vẫn Cốt nó tối ưu vẫn ngon hơn so
với rất nhiều trang hiện tại đây các bạn
lên đây Trang nữa trả công với tính năng
gì đã trả không Cái bài toán đi Vụ gì cả
rơi vào vật ôm Và thậm chí à Nó làm được
quét hai cái gì đó nó đều không Thế là
cốt các bạn bây giờ hiện tại và tính ra
nó sản phẩm trí tuệ các bạn vẫn là rất
chịu rồi vẫn đang giá giá trị nên là
thực cả các bạn hạn chế việc chia sẻ nó
có thể thứ
Ừ đấy thì có thể ở ngay bây giờ các bạn
có thể gỡ hết quyền
không lắp nick nó nữa Trừ khi các bạn hả
muốn
mình review qua cốt thì mẹ các bạn có
thể cậu thêm mình vào so với sau có thể
vỡ quyền mình đi mình hoàn toàn thoải
mái vừa đẩy Khoái Châu và tôi vẫn đang
đang nói là mấy ông nên tôn trọng chính
sản phẩm mấy ông làm ra ông ạ
Ê mấy ông mà không trân trọng Trình đứa
con tinh thần của mình làm ra thì sẽ
không ai trên Chọn nó đúng chết đấy thế
phải có cái tôi về cái đấy à
Ừ nếu hiểu không ạ
tôi
nói chung là cách nói chuyện của tôi mấy
ông thấy rõ rồi cái dại của tôi đó là
tôi luôn chú trọng các bạn cũng như là
kiểu ở hướng đến các bạn như không phải
là như Face sâu nữa mà đang hướng dẫn
hưởng đến An Junior rất là người biết
làm và tôn trọng như là đồng nghiệp các
rồi thứ rồi Nên là các bạn phải nên cư
xử nó cũng kiểu như thế cứ xử cơ sở của
chính bản thân mình Đó là như một video
rồi các bạn sẽ phải ạ
có phải cũng có cái gọi là cũng phải
không Không đến tự ti và thân nữa mà
cũng sẽ phải có cái tôi cũng kiểu dạng
phải là mạnh mẽ hơn đấy các thứ vân vân
hơn chục chết chứ chứ không phải là kiểu
cốt cốt Minh kia đều vẫn là rác hay các
thứ tự đừng nên nghĩ thế
à Tôi quen rất nhiều người có tội nên và
người đấy Đúng nghĩa là học hành không
tử tế thứ Nếu không nghĩ thế không ạ ạ
nít Ừ có mỗi con nít của mấy ông đều
thôi Thế thôi không nhận
không còn ít bạn kẹo chán à
Tôi không biết nhưng mà bây ông ngồi con
nít như
như đùa vậy đấy rồi cũng phải tôn trọng
cốt của chính mình là mình sẽ phải con
nít tử tế vào đây mày còn biết điều đặt
biệt đẩy lên cho có chết à
không xin bảo vệ nữa thì hôm nay sẽ tặng
kết hôn ở đây thì liệu trình giống như
mình vừa nãy nói bạn thể tôi ở xem lại
sau nha
Thế còn bạn nó thoáng mát gì không nhỉ
thắc mắc gì về bảo vệ đoán hay là về đồ
án gì lịch trình như thế nào không
quần với với quay builder nhanh không ạ
Mình có hướng dẫn qua về áo quần và với
bị đơ đấy là học thì chắc là chỉ có thể
trang chủ thôi đương như trang chủ thì
vẫn khẳng định là rất nhiều người khiến
nghỉ việc ở trang chủ của Eriol nó nó cứ
kiểu bị lừa nạc nửa mỡ nó đúng là nó có
lý chi tiết thật nhưng mà không phù hợp
ít ví dụ cho người mới học còn với người
mà chuyên sâu rồi thì ra nó lại không
đầy đủ bởi vì có rất nhiều cái hàm trên
đấy nó không hề nhắc đến nhưng mà trong
cái api của nó thì có giống ở đây này
Hãy thế nên là
Anh tính ra là thứ nhất là vẫn phải học
thời trang chủ chắc chắn nhưng mà nhưng
mà để về sau chuyên sâu hơn thì vẫn phải
thêm mua thêm tài liệu đấy lý do mà có
rất nhiều người vẫn Đản bán khóa tài
liệu rodder có từ thứ ấy trả chỉ có thể
thế thôi và tự nhiên là giống như các
bạn thấy em mình vẫn nằm ở hai cái tát
thường xuyên này thì mình sẽ thỉnh
thoảng mình có mua vài khóa tài liệu
không những là leo có thể chuyện có thể
kéo về à atwell nâng cao havan mình sẽ
thường xuyên chia sẻ mẹo thêm cho các
bạn sau điều hòa thì thôi Chào mấy ông
nhé
ừ ừ